okay so ariane maybe a problem with the
camera we'll try and get that fixed as
we go along magnus looking confused
there but as simon mentioned it's a bit
of a surprise it's the french defense
and we've only seen the french defense
played a handful of times so far on the
tour this season it's very rare at the
top level actually uh more popular
popular at club level tournament level
maybe but uh yeah magnus he wheels out
this opening once in a blue moon so a
bit of a surprise and uh aryan reacting
by bringing the white knight out
protecting the center and black's bishop
coming out means we're gonna get a
really feisty game in this one simon
you're a bit of an expert yourself on
the french defense yeah i certainly i
mean this position i i've had
hundreds of times before it's also
included in some courses that i've done
and
the move that magnus plays here actually
was one of the first moves ever taught
to me uh this this this little move here
which might look a little bit strange
when i was about seven years old i
remember my dad told me this move
because
the point is you're trying to swap off
one of white's best pieces um which is
uh that that bishop next to the king uh
can be a very dangerous piece but in
general french defense i i think is is a
very exciting opening actually
you can if you go back historically it
was like the games between mikhail tao
and makita botfonic and the world
championships and their games was so
fascinating in the french defense and
it's around then when the opening got
quite popular i know that
nepo has been using the french defense
as well as uh recently with the black
pieces so it's uh it's it's pretty you
know it's a good opening definitely a
very good opening i think one of the
players uh a couple of the players maybe
in this uh event have done chattable
courses on the french defense definitely
a nishikiri anishigiri and i think
pentala hari krishna as well oh french
toast yeah yeah i think that's the
french
defense so maybe these players will have
studied their opponents uh or some of
their rivals accessible courses
meanwhile a few strange moves have been
happening um we saw black's bishop when
it was attacked go the whole way back
magnus is trying some really creative
stuff but definitely don't try this at
home i was looking at this david just
just a month ago when i was playing the
break vic open
i was preparing this this this actual
position uh against max um from a very
strong player um from uh holland and i
looked at this position because i
thought i don't want my opponent to
attack because you know so much theory
can i get a position where i can play
easily and i looked at this and i
thought i'm not sure i like it that much
for black you know so i actually gave up
and the assessment at this position is
supposed to be it's a little bit better
for white but maybe this doesn't bother
magnus he just wants something solid uh
to play yeah and he is solid for now
black because the center's closed it
doesn't matter that all of black's
pieces are still asleep on its uh on
their original squares so i mean
i would never ever do this personally i
would never undevelop a piece like
magnus has done he's bringing his black
square bishop back
maybe we can show this on the board
because it is really committal uh but
yeah as simon says black is solid enough
for now and it will get arianne thinking
for himself and it was this move that i
found so shocking black's bishop has
just come to the square two moves ago
and now after it got kicked away by this
pawn it stepped the whole way back to
its starting square um the whole reason
is that you don't want to block in this
knight this knight wants to develop but
undeveloping your pieces like this is
not to be recommended in general unless
you're the world champion of course and
uh okay white gave a check hitting the
black king this was blocked white
stepped back and uh after white night
after the white knight also stepped back
um here in this position it's all a
battle about whether black can get his
pieces out are there enough squares
black is super cramped how are these
pieces ever going to enter the game i
mean i would have thought here that
black really needs to be to play bishop
be to basically try to attack white's
bishop because if white gets one more
moving if white's able to move a pawn to
where the white knight came from it just
it just looks really nice white uh he's
managed to you know shore his center so
yeah this is a nice pawn chain for white
you've locked everything down and so you
think this move simon trading the bishop
i think this is amazing the line this is
the main line yeah and you guys even
looking at this kind of stuff before um
you've got to try to get rid of this
bishop because it might look good but it
is it's not very good black's bishop
yeah if the bishops do come off then at
least now the more trades that have
happened the more black frees up his
position and suddenly the black knight
has a good square at least and these
double pawns aren't such a big weakness
you could push one of them forward later
to trade off
yeah looks like a good move magnus
thinking but we're expecting this bishop
move ivanka is this a popular line you
say it's been played before this bishop
move it's it's been played on i would
say about uh 30 games sorry is it
reasonable um but i do think that
simon's move that he suggested which is
the main move it might not be knowledge
for a person that doesn't regularly play
the french defense and you know we just
seen that magnus is kind of like a hobby
french player you know he plays it once
in a while
because you have certain openings that
you know they're not your bread and
butter so you don't quite know the
subtleties so to speak so so like for
instance i didn't even think about this
bishop bishop trade that simon thought
about and he knew instinctively okay
you've got to stop that bishop from
getting to a beautiful diagonal you've
got to stop white from reinforcing the
pawn trade i was thinking you know that
bishop looks great on that diagonal just
keep it there so uh that's kind of those
are the that's the reason why i kind of
referred to magnus being a
hobby
hobby player no i didn't say hobby
player just a hobby player i said
so this is like a paper they twist the
words don't they you just take it out of
context
if anchor called magnus a hobby player
headlines everywhere this magnus is
looking well to his left a moment ago
and uh that normally means that he's
trying to remember something but it
looks like he was trying to remember
something he couldn't quite recall what
the main move was for example simon's
bishop moving okay when in doubt push
the h pawn oh look at the bar with that
move yeah and this just i think
computers won't like this because now
black can never really castle on that
side of the board the black king if ever
tries to castle onto the king side the
right side of the board then that black
pawn has actually pushed too far forward
it's a weakness that white can attack
later
but magnus is trying to take control
over the dark squares so
uh sorry uh over
uh as much territory as possible so okay
it makes some sense pushing forward but
the black king is probably doomed to
stay in the center for a long time risky
stuff
it turns out simon you have 27 published
chessboard courses according to buddy
27. yeah that's a lot fun really not
that many can't be that many i don't i
mean they think
i mean i know i know they locked me in a
basement and said you've got to work for
the next two months before we feed you
but i didn't realize it went on that
long i'm joking i wanted to do them but
it can't be 27 27 published courses
because how many hours of video does
many of those courses have they're all
about at least 10 hours some of them
have some of them are 30 hours so uh so
it's a lot that's a lot of video i mean
27 maybe 27 videos including other
companies i work for but it can't be 27
chess pool i don't believe it i believe
you've done quite a lot though i've done
it i've done a lot yeah i've done a lot
about 27.
it's my life gone let's say yeah we need
more of our views to verify that fact so
check out
simon williams no i do i do love making
the courses obviously and it's a
pleasure to do so but 27 is a lot isn't
it yeah that's a lot of courses
it's my age i wish
and mine it's like that moment when you
count up all the shoes you've got in
your closet and you're like oh yeah i
did that the other day actually it was a
catastrophe yeah
yep
all right we have oh another
move by harry yeah talking of
catastrophe this could be bad for black
if he's not careful but magnus he needs
to get his pieces out so uh ariana with
white just blocking black sage pawn so
we've got kind of a locked up
locked up situation there on the right
half of the board but magnus taking the
time to eventually develop the black
knight but if you look at black's dark
square bishop in front of the black king
that piece has moved three times out of
black's first 10 moves
and it's not on that greatest square
anyway so black's lost a lot of time
white needs to do something quick in
order to
kind of profit from that so i still like
white's position but there is a big
question what to do next often computers
miss evaluate positions from a human
point of view because they think okay
you have a space advantage which white
does here in the center you have more
active pieces better developed pieces
which white kind of does but
still no plan forward for a human player
i assumed white's idea was to
uh yeah play this movie's playing and
just bring the bishop back to that
square
um and then maybe exchange the bishop
for black's knight and have well maybe a
quite a nice strategic position with
some bishop g5s and e6 breaks so it's
just uh this this seems like a very
natural plan and i think you're right
the computer is definitely over
evaluating white's position because it's
a blocked structure and computers don't
evaluate block structures as maybe as
well as they should do this is the type
of position where if one computer played
another computer white would win but it
would take 100 something moves anyway so
from a human point of view that's less
likely to happen and we should of course
say a few words about aryanthari the
second highest rated player in norway
after magnus carlsen of course he's been
a second for anish giri at least i know
so he must be quite good with the
openings he's very good with the
openings i remember back in what was it
2017 now he knocked me out of the world
cup because he was so well prepared in
the openings i would often struggle to
get any advantage when i had white and
when i was black i was always on the
back foot from an early stage so
yeah i mean he's he's very very strong
he's broken through slightly lately yeah
he's pushing slowly towards that 2700
mark which kind of signifies um the real
kind of creme de la creme but
yeah i think
it's been a great thing for him having
magnus kind of as that role model for
him to
aspire to but at the same time it must
be hard always being the number two
right always being compared to the world
champion do you think magnus is a good
role model for aaron yeah i mean uh
chastise at least definitely
why not i mean imagine having the world
champion hanging out playing practice
games they're very close they've played
on the same international team for years
and i was just thinking you know just
that ability to play blitz against the
world champion and just think about it
you know you managed to test your wits
for hundreds of games
and if you manage to score something
great if you don't it's a learning
experience and
and only 22 years old
he is a lot younger than magnus girls
and almost 10 years younger former world
junior champion yeah i think so yeah
there's still a lot of room for him uh
to improve and
and it's looking good i guess in this
first game against uh his fellow
norwegian he's very good in the opening
sky
and uh yeah i mean you don't become a
second for someone like anish giri
without knowing your stuff so
ariane i think that's why maybe magnus
went for something a bit offbeat a bit
rare unusual he's just trying to survive
the opening and take the game into kind
of muddier waters but
this last move by black yes it's locking
down the light squares but look at all
of black's pawns they're mostly on light
squares that means you don't control the
dark squares
and
yeah some of simon's ideas might come
into play a bit later maybe we can jump
in show what aryan is thinking about
right now
and it's all to do with maybe the dark
squares this one maybe this one later on
you could start by thinking about
trading bishops
this definitely looks like black's best
piece and it's moved about a lot so you
might as well say to your opponent okay
you've moved about but you're just
you've just wasted time i'm gonna trade
you off i don't really see what black
does next move to be honest i guess you
bring the knight in but as simon also
mentioned at some point now white can
drop the bishop back and trade off this
strong knight
and that pawn structure is going to
favor white
does feel like that magnus is probably
in wait and see mode you know he has to
just react and uh they we see the bishop
move on the board
um
just make a few no moves you know just
yeah i mean i think you're just a little
bit worse aren't you a black hair
because it's white who's who's pushing
with these ideas and it's very hard to
come up with an active plan for black i
mean
i mean look at what black can do i mean
black i was thinking this move might
well be worth doing because the knights
could become extremely good the more
closed the position is so i think this
makes sense at least getting rid of one
of white's knights and swapping that off
but white i mean black would love to do
a pawn break here and the normal pawn
break you'd try to play in the french
defense is this is this move here um
with the pawn to try to put some
pressure on white center without this
pawn break it's very hard for black to
get any counter players as you say your
vancory just has to kind of wait and
just uh wait and see what um
you know terry's going to come up with
there so a little bit better definitely
for what yeah and unfortunately for
black this desirable move you said uh
you mentioned it's not possible because
of this pin so just by logic there maybe
black can get his king out of the way
maybe plant it on this square which is
relatively safe you're not castling but
you're kind of guiding your king towards
safety and then next move potentially
um you can start pushing forward and
putting some pressure on white's
stronghold in the center but it's very
slow for black also white is spoiled for
choice which way do we think white's
going to castle
there are arguments for both sides
on the board also white has the
luxury of maybe even taking as much
space as possible on the wings and
i'm just kind of using pattern
recognition okay and we see magnus kind
of abandoned this idea of pushing the
sea pawn forward and instead
i think he's just trying to lock down
the position do you think ivanka after
white's bishop moves away from the
attack is he going to play this and look
at what black's pawn structure now all
on the light squares
i mean this is so weird
um looks like a mountain chain yeah like
alps i think you know what i think he's
going to do that he's going to do
something he's going to do something
similar like that and but then again you
know it's white who has the luxury of
opening up the position they have the
pawn breaks and like you've kind of said
you know the white king has the
flexibility to go to the right go to the
left and go either side and
once again magnus it has to wait in a
constructive way which is not easy
actually yeah that being said uh i mean
it seems that we generally like white's
position here in the studio but it's
still hard for white to find the
breakthrough black is rock solid because
of this pawn chain um this is quite good
strategy in general once you've kind of
traded off your light squared bishop put
your pawns on light squares so you can
control the light squares and okay here
we go ariane because he's got the bishop
pair now because he's got a bit more
space he's trying to accelerate the play
end there we go we do get that pawn
structure
on
yeah definitely it's strange you you
hardly ever see that
in a in the match between two two strong
players at this level so is it good is
it bad i i mean generally you have to be
very careful because as david said if
you put all your pawns on right squares
as you do here the opposite color
becomes very weak because you can't
guard any of the dark squares with your
pawns so you can see all the light
squares where black's pawns are they're
only attacking light squares so the dark
squares therefore are
holes um very hard for white to get in
in them but yeah maybe but so that white
dark squared bishop is that now a very
strong piece for aryan
potentially uh i mean we could imagine a
situation where actually the dark
squared bishops come off because white
starts growing potentially strong but
black's dark square bishop is the only
guardian of the dark squares so it does
make some sense to maybe trade off those
dark squared bishops and then later
white's knight will try to creep into
the dark squares black's knights their
main job will be stopping white's knight
getting in
i think the main problem for aryan
potentially is that white's
light-squared bishop is just kind of
hitting against concrete
that's why black's pawns have kind of
created this strong rock-solid formation
white's bishop the light squad bishop
may be lacking a future but if things do
open up it's going to favor ariane if he
can creep into the dark squares it's
going to favor ariane i think magnus
just has to hope that he can trade off
as many pieces as possible for example i
think it would be a small mistake here
for the pawns on okay he cast was his
king very logical i was going to say to
release the tension and trade off a set
of pawns on the a file
that would be a mistake because you
don't want to open up lines trade off
rooks trade off everything because if
you trade things off you have nothing
left white you have no advantage
black is got no weaknesses and uh i
think you have to keep the tension and
magnus look at this he's not to the side
of the board he's trying to force ariane
to block things up even more if you
block things up that will favor black's
knights
so uh key decision now for aryan
that's certainly a key decision you know
do you
do you know do you
are you kind of go into the temptation
of just blocking up the position by
saying hey i got all the space or are
you just going to
make another improving move and maybe
try to control the knight's circuit and
very tense positions so far
and
whilst the players are pausing for
thought um i did want to share with you
we have a quiz of the day where we're
asking what is the thing you struggle
with the most in the openings and george
charman says i love nothing more than
sucking pawns in the opening it's very
far cry from this position
for a promising attack only to realize
three moves later i'm dead last time
perhaps i need some ginger gm magic yes
what would be a good chestable chorus
for him then simon uh the towel course
um there's a course by mikhail tao
or the art of attack which is another
course about how to attack and how to
sacrifice so either of those ones are
all about attacking in chess so the art
of attack very famous book that uh did
the videos for or the the tower course
which is just about this crazy attacker
so they will help you
um well maybe a little bit you know lose
lose uh sack those pawns but maybe not
in a losing way
yeah if your instinct is to sacrifice
don't kill that instinct
yeah i mean you should do i mean like i
think in chess you should always play
the way you want to play because it's
more fun but i i have to say i really
don't like what aaron's done here he's
basically i think gone for the draw here
maybe maybe i'm being a little bit
critical but why close down the queen
side you didn't need to do that i mean
in order you know it just doesn't look
like the right strategy from white there
personally yeah we've seen one side of
the
board completely locked down now nothing
really is ever going to happen on the
left half of the board so players
switched completely over to the right
half
and uh magnus he's dancing with his
knights he would love to trade off one
set of knights now if white's knight
disappears white has no chance of
winning this game um so magnus he wants
to bring this black knight that's just
moved to the top of the board over again
to challenge white's knight and
if those knights disappear maybe we can
show that david where white decided to
block down okay they're gonna have a bit
of maneuvering here so we can come back
to the position but nothing's going to
happen immediately so just a few moves
ago yeah it was just this moment where
uh ariane decided to play his pawn
forwards here and you can see after this
move there's nothing that can be done on
the queen side there's no pawn breaks so
as we see everything's locked up as dave
mentioned but if we go back aryan could
have even just taken the pawn let's say
he takes the pawn this keeps the
position more open it gives more winning
chances to both sides but if you want to
win you've got to you've got to keep
some open lines you can't block the
whole position down so maybe this is a
tactile draw offer i would have thought
but i don't know seems a bit strange
yeah there was no rush either i mean for
example at the minimum you could lift
your rook up the board swing the other
rook across try to open up this line
yeah just keep the tension don't commit
when you have so many options
and if we fast forward to the current
position
ivanka what do you think any chance now
for white to break through i mean it
looks very unlikely it does look very
unlikely and the only thing i can see is
that you know it's a closed position so
therefore everything will hinge on a
pawn break on this opening and the only
opening there is is actually to pick up
a pawn on the right side and
unfortunately unfortunately the white
king is there so i envisage that if
ariana is feeling in an aggressive mood
his king is going to take on a
herculean journey over to the blocked up
side of the board and
then
initiate something on the right side
yeah for example if you could pick up
the white king and plant it on this side
of the board where it's completely
blocked completely safe then you can
start launching pawns forward as javan
conventions for example this one even if
it comes at the cost of a porn later
just to explode open the position to
open up lines but the problem is firstly
this journey with the white king takes a
long time and uh secondly even if you
achieve that black's king is going to be
equally safe on this side of the board
and opening things up here still looks
like a distant dream uh black has kind
of locked down the only possible pawn
break to open up lines it's it does seem
though that white has all the winning
chances even in what probably is a very
locked position because again with a
position so locks as you mentioned you
think you have to look at pawn breaks
and black hasn't really got any pawns
that he can move that ever his only one
is moving this pawn next to the queen
but that will just make his position
worse so
white does have a pawn break to attack
the knight even if it takes ages to
arrange he's still got potential and
often it's who's got the potential in
the position white's got potential in
his position black doesn't have
potential and that means white's got
better chances here yeah and as you
mentioned simon there just to show on
the board if black ever pushes this pawn
um for example if white waits if you
ever push this pawn you only help open
up towards your weaknesses black just
has to sit and hope but magnus is quite
good at sitting and he's very good at
kind of doing nothing just kind of slow
maneuvering moves getting ready for the
action to really happen and yeah the
status quo it was going to be maintained
for a long long time i feel it seems
it's a calming little nervous start to
chasable monsters the bars and most of
the games as we see on the bottom of the
screen is
roughly to the middle i do see that
mamadiara of the bar is liking it for
him against eric hanson
other than that maybe for ding against
jordan van faris the bar slightly over
to ding's side
but so far a calm start to the chestable
master so when will it explode i do
suspect it will explode at some time we
know it will the tour this season has
been crazy so many decisive games barely
any draws no quick draws at least
and uh yeah the players when they find
their stride that's when we'll see the
action yeah and no one wants to get that
bad start so i guess
do you think when we look at stats we're
gonna see some different openings maybe
more solid
non-losing kind of openings in the first
few games
well you know traditionally yeah that is
the thing you would see but in this tour
in these tournaments so far no the
players have been playing with wild
abandon and they just they've just been
playing fighting
for sorry fighting chat from the very
start from the very very start and uh
you know magnus is actually renowned for
being a slow starter that's true yeah
you know maybe maybe even losing the
first game and then just getting off
quietly and then kicking into gear so
yeah
i don't expect that at all i think maybe
this one if it's a draw
you know and i expect fully expect it to
be a draw i suspect the other games
there's probably fireworks on the board
yeah there's at least two or three of
those other games which i think are
going to uh
produce decisive results produce some
winners and okay a trade a bishop
overnight do you know what david i was
thinking about this and i thought if
white really wants to draw yeah he could
bring his knight back to g5 and go f4
and there's like there's nothing there
at all like i can see but he hasn't gone
for that okay he's playing still playing
for a win then i think he's livening up
slightly so there is a semi-open file
now towards the white king and actually
there was a big trick a big trap if
arianne had been greedy and grabbed this
uh this isolated pawn looks like white
as wonderful and then suddenly queen
takes pawn would win for black because
this pin means the queen is untouchable
and suddenly the white king too open
so aryan had to dodge that he had to get
his king out the way and the black
knight retreating now defending the
spawn and aryan just pushing this pawn
forward simon you mentioned the complete
draw and
i think we're going to see that any
moment if these knights disappear
there's no chance for the major pieces
um yeah i mean for example you could
just trade here and then just lock
things up bring your queen to this
square bring your rook across to defend
this pawn
yeah no weaknesses for either side this
is the thing if white had an open line
on the queen side which she could have
had white white could still try to win
this position because uh the old uh
saying is you you've got to play against
two weaknesses black's kind of got a
weakness with the harry porn i would say
um so you but you need another weakness
to win this game let's go back to the
players we're going to see a draw any
moment look at this pawn structure as
well strange this is the most locked
pawn structure you will ever see
simply nothing to do neither side can
push forward without losing a pawn and
uh look how kind of irrelevant the rooks
are here no open lines for them and i'm
gonna see the kings do a bit of dancing
that's it uh and ariane's king has
wandered all the way is it gonna come
back again are they gonna repeat moves
actually by just moving the kings
backwards and forwards magnus is
repeating no doubt about that and we
have a draw between the two norwegians
in a very strange pawn situation on this
board i want to take a picture of that